I run a Yoga Center a block from here  yes and I do everything literally  everything of course any advice is it  bothering you right now can you afford  to hire an entry-level employee to do  the shift that you most hate doing no  but I could work on making more money as  soon as you know can you charge more for  your service  I know you can it's the fear of raising  the price that kills solo entrepreneurs  by you having the courage to walk one  block over and changing the price from  80 an hour to 120 you can then hire that  person and her competitors are not real  competitors even because you're uniquely  you and whoever likes doing it with you  likes doing it with you that's true  there is no [ __ ] competitor we have  the juice the competitor is your [ __ ]  head telling you [ __ ] that's not true  like I can't who am I to raise it 20  bucks that person I think is doing a  good job is ten dollars less  that's who's [ __ ] you up that's your  competitor